all anyone can talk about right now are
crypto batteries who are ruining
valorent ranked and throwing everyone's
matches and this has been happening for
quite a while now so everyone's just
waiting to see what Riot will do about
it but will they ever fix it
[Music]
before we get into the video I just want
to remind you guys that we recently
released new cream and black colors of
our touchgrass hoodie so head to
shop.thescore.com to check them out the
Valerie ranked season ends next week and
I know a lot of you have been going
through it but for a lot of pros and
content creators things have gotten
extreme if you've been watching Annie
Valerian streams lately then you've
probably seen it
so that raise who just ran it down onto
site and died is an alleged ranked
crypto better and if you're wondering
what the [__] I just said well let me
explain I've heard rumors of this for
well over a year now but the earliest
mention that I could find is this tweet
from we did back in August of last year
he posted this screenshot that allegedly
shows a site where people can use
various cryptocurrencies to bet on
streamers ranked matches so you might be
thinking yeah it's kind of weird that
these people are betting on random
ranked matches but who cares while the
problem is that these people are also
throwing these matches whether it's they
themselves or someone they know these
Bettors find a way to throw these
streamers matches and manipulate the
outcome so that they can win their
payout and over the past few months it's
gotten really bad bro someone bet on our
[__] game in as much as we know about
it how do you know he's messaging me
about it he's like a girl I'm like you
know as if you didn't believe about the
crypto throwers from one of the websites
and you have to understand my position
it's frustrating right it's frustrating
when you guys deliberately throw games
yeah it's gotten pretty off for a lot of
these streamers now if you're a fan of
League of Legends then there's nothing
new here this has been going on in
league for way longer and Danny even
covered that story on our Channel a
couple years ago so there's an entire
betting site in China where people can
bet on whether or not A League of
Legends Pro will win or lose their solo
queue game on stream players discovered
that illegal betting sites existed where
you could bet on pro-korean solo key
matches in the exact same way these
Bettors would win trade their way into
High ELO so that they and their friends
could grief top players and win their
bet this didn't last though because Riot
Korea eventually took action Banning
over 10 000 accounts and establishing a
hotline where lck teams can report any
suspicious players for suspected win
trading or illegal gambling now sure
this helps some of the pro players who
were getting griefed but they weren't
the only ones facing off against the
Bettors and win Traders and because of
this plenty of streamers continue to
suffer and some of them are so sick and
tired of this [__] that they have
encouraged Their audience to get in on
the fun and make a quick Buck I mean
just bet on my games and I'll and by the
way we hold a chat bit I mean it doesn't
matter it's gonna happen so why don't we
hold a chat like a thing a Poland chat
I'll tell you guys you want me to win or
lose this game you guys chat pull it and
then whatever chat poll is I'll do it I
mean it doesn't matter Ryan's not doing
anything maybe we just like full on rig
the bet so that the bit like if if Riot
won't do something maybe the betting
companies themselves will do something
and I can stop it so you can't bet on my
games it's like we all bet on the same
thing it'll be like too biased or
whatever that tyler1 clip is only a few
months old and it's pretty clear that
he's sick of this [__] so rather than
waiting for something to be done about
it he just decided to rig any bets
placed on his matches and now every
valorant Pro is experiencing this exact
same thing some players are begging for
some sort of FPL or maybe even a
Champions Q that's similar to League
because the normal ranked system feels
so bad for them okay AFK just ruining my
game
he doesn't get both I asked ethos what
he thinks about the whole situation and
here's what he had to say when there's
someone who's literally acting to try
and throw and try to lose on your team
it's just it's such a waste of time
you're not getting good practice and it
makes people upset and I understand yeah
you can make money you know what get
your bag right like do like do whatever
you need but like to ruin the experience
for
no I just get nine other people in that
game but also all the people watching
this stream it's just kind of scummy
it's just kind of scummy I think it it
definitely sucks a lot and I I really
hate the fact that it's a thing it
really is ruining I mean ranked it was
bad enough it already sucked people
already sucked in me we don't need
people intentionally thought people were
already you know unintentionally
throwing so it's like we don't need
people to to to try and throw these
games
that's enough enough is enough
cryptobetters have been around in league
for a long time and clearly that's now
spilled over to Valerie so hopefully
Riot does something soon because right
now there's a lot of people who are sick
of all the nonsense that's going on in
ranked
these Bettors find a way to throw these
streamers matches and manipulate why
can't I say manipulate today I'm having
a [__] brain aneurysm
okay I'll breathe these Bettors find a
way to throw these streamers matches and
manipulate the outcome so that they can
rig the bed
[__] this is what happens when you make
me wake up at 8am